his 19th season at Iowa Kirk Ferentz
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
coach I'm doing well rich how about you
I'm doing fine how let's start with this
one how health players changed since you
first stepped on a campus and I was the
head coach there and now yeah it's
almost been 20 years and I actually came
here in 81 as an assistant so my history
at Iowa goes back a long ways
yeah I think overall you know players
haven't changed all that much I think
the world's changed around us obviously
and probably the biggest factor there
would be the social media and just you
know the explosion of information that's
out there and how do you handle that
well you know you try to control it you
try to understand what voices players
are here and I think that's been true
forever I guess
the biggest change now is just some of
those voices are a little bit more
widespread and it's no different than
the world of coaching you know we used
to be that you know people always had
opinions at the taverns or the
barbershop this type of thing but now
it's everywhere so from that standpoint
things have changed a lot and I think
you have the probably thing it's changed
you know that's really impacted
recruiting and not all in a healthy way
and you know one thing I've witnessed I
think it seems like a lot of appearance
and not my wife and our parents of three
boys that played high school football
you know it's not always the healthiest
message is being sent out there and you
know the game to me has never been about
earning a scholarship or going to the
NFL it's been more about the experience
and all the benefits that you can gather
from playing as Atlanta sport league
football Kirk Ferentz of Iowa football
joining me here on the show and yeah you
were obviously an assistant under Hayden
Fry for those years in Iowa and then
spent some time in Maine being a head
coach and then join the staff of a coach
named Bill Belichick in Cleveland when
do when did you first ever cross paths
with Bill Belichick laughs I'm still
trying to figure out why I got hired and
Cleveland I think part of the I know
part of the reason is I think about six
or seven guys turned it down before that
I got to me on the list I swear I think
that's true but anyway I'm not sure how
it all happened we did have a mutual
friend a coach named Tom Bresnahan Tom
had been really really good to me
throughout my career and always has been
a mentor and just a tremendous guy he
worked for
leave you but Tom and Bill work together
in New York so I'm guessing that might
be where the connection all started but
I'll say it was a rough interview I
never got beat up so bad and you know
I'm sure I was I was certain I didn't
get the job and next thing you know I
was back going back for a second
interview so it's one of the great
things that happened in my life just
those were three great years and I'm
remained very very appreciative of that
experience how did you how did coach
Belichick beat you up in the interview
I'm talking about a stone face I mean
you know everything I said he just
looked at me and so I was dying a
thousand deaths after every answer that
I gave him it just was really it was a
tough interview you know and he he's
very thorough as you might imagine asked
very good questions and you know at the
essence of the whole thing I'd been a
head coach and at that time one double a
football four through three years so
after the first interview said hey I
really appreciate your honesty he says
you know I think you know you're a
straight-up guy that way but I worry
about your tech technical knowledge and
that type of thing but somehow we
overcame it and we were able to hook up
well what's your relationship like with
him now I know that he's had one of your
son's on his staff how would you
categorize him now that's been great I
mean he's been nothing but helpful in my
career and I'm very much indebted just
first and foremost for what I learned
from him and just you know having a
chance an opportunity to work with him
for three years you can't help but learn
and also appreciative of the fact that
they were very kind of let her oldest
boy Brian work there and he was there
for four four years I guess it would
have been and you know you can't he
can't find a better graduate school to
go to so I mean gave him a chance Brian
a chance to to get out of the Iowa
football way of doing things and see
another place and see how things are
really done and I can't imagine there's
a better place if you want to talk about
doing things right there there can't be
a better place I mean knowing I'm
Patriots Kirk Ferentz joining me here on
the show and then before we get to your
current situation I'm just fascinated by
the steps of your career how close did
you ever come to being a head coach in
the NFL you know I've had some
opportunities since I've been here but
right now that really this this whole
thing was when we came here in 99 I was
all about our family quite frankly I was
I was hopeful you know certainly you
never bet on this but I was hopeful
maybe we'd have an opportunity to let
our kid
no we're homeless and a lot of things I
really am grateful for about being a
Nile with at one time is it
we've had our kids we have five kids
they've all graduated from one high
school and they have a sense of where
home is they've got a community that
they can call home and you know that's
hard to do in this profession so I'm
really really appreciative of that well
in terms of Kirk Ferentz here from Iowa
when you've been at Iowa what's the
closest you've ever been to thinking you
know up maybe I will go take that head
coaching gig in the NFL oh yeah I mean
there might have been one or two things
that were intriguing
you know I'd put it that way but you
know at the end of the day it really
just kind of get back to what what are
your priorities and and you know for us
every move I've tried to make you know
it was always dictated on two things you
know what was the opportunity like not
the the financial and but the
opportunity who would you be working
with you know how would you grow but the
other component is you know once Mary
and I started a family in 1983 then you
know you put the family first and
foremost so I've been really fortunate
coming back here the one thing I knew
coming back you know working for Coach
Frey for nine years I knew this is a
place where if you did things right
you'd have a chance to be successful
else and do the margin for errors really
slim here so you know you take that
stuff into account but you know we just
we just have a really a great comfort
level not only the university but the
entire state this is just a place we
enjoy living it's been really good to us
and I've always told people to you know
if you're gonna leave somewhere I think
you need a compelling reason to and I've
never felt like I've had that here a few
more minutes with Kirk Ferentz
Iowa Hawkeye head football coach let's
talk about your team right now in the
Big Ten how deep is this conference
compared to the obviously 19 seasons you
have been a head coach in it right now
you know we've always said like every
conference I think you've always had
some really good teams at the top and
that that hasn't changed but I think
yeah the balance of power and certainly
the 85 scholarship rule you know coming
back here that made a difference so that
that parts in in play as well and then
we've got outstanding coaches but you
know we've had a lot of good coaches
come through this conference so but our
league right now it's you know
everybody's everybody's competitive and
one of the great things about conference
football and it's probably true in every
conference that you know
you got to prepare a week in and week
out and and certainly from where we said
I mentioned in our margin for error work
truly a developmental team I think any
good team is but you know we our best
teams at least have come a long way they
get a lot better as the season goes on
so you know the month of September for
us is about finding a way to win and
trying to figure out you know who our
players are and what they can do and and
then trying to coach the best at the
best we can to put them in a position
where they can be successful so you know
the leaks competitive weekend week out
and you know we've always got our work
to do
okay and you played Wyoming this past
week as I'm sure you know of Wyoming's
quarterback Josh Allen and there's a lot
of Pro eyes that have been on this kid
how did he look to you knowing obviously
what it takes to send somebody to the
next level and being I was watching the
dress and I'm one of those people that
watches it to the end if I'm allowed to
my wife let me do it though you know
last April and I'm watching on Saturday
you know and you know they get bored in
the sixth round so they started thought
about next year's draft and next day
another time at the quarterback from
Wyoming I'm gonna holy smokes I didn't
you know I know I don't want to wear
that in April so he's a real deal he's
just a really impressive guy he's got
all the physical tools he's a big guy
that can run move looks down the field
when he runs you know just he's a really
impressive guy and his demeanor on the
field just everything about him was
really impressive so I think we probably
hit 10 and I felt people here including
a couple GM's and I know they weren't
here to watch us so come on now coach
come on now you you sent many a kid to
the next level with outstanding careers
come on well probably not gonna make a
GM come out of his office on the day of
transaction so I think I think that the
quarterback the day of transit you know
what's going on it's Dave transactions
for sure and you make a lot of roster
moves left Saturday well I mean one of
the surprises of the draft this year was
CJ Beathard being drafted when he was
coach and you know obviously his name
came up in the last week with Ed
Cunningham being a long time announcer
retiring because of his qualms with the
sports violence and then pointing out
how he thought that you're you and your
coaching staff put him in harm's way and
I'd love to give you the floor on any
response you have to that I appreciate
that
first of all just on CJ you know it
really wasn't a surprise to us the only
surprise I think was you know you hear
our local media was talking about you
know what the experts were saying and
they weren't saying much about CJ and
that that to me was surprising but
thinking about watch CJ play over the
last couple of years and it's seen my
sense was there's about four or five
teams in the NFL that were hot on his
trail and obviously San Francisco traded
up to get him I think they're trying to
move in front of somebody that somebody
else is interested so and I read coach
Han has comments about CJ when they did
draft him and boy he just nailed the kid
I mean it's CJ's one of the best players
I've ever been around what a football
player and you know the comments what I
didn't appreciate about the comments the
article I read at least we kind of got
lumped into a situation that dealt with
head trauma and you know to me you talk
about apples and oranges there this was
a soft tissue issue issue and there's no
question CJ was limited in that part of
the game but again if you know the full
story
I mean CJ's career was defined by
toughness if you think about a year ago
what he did he led us to an undefeated
season twelve oh no in the regular
season and played the majority of that
season with a sports hernia and there's
nothing fun about that it's extremely
painful and there were days where he
couldn't walk basically and we played up
at Northwestern we didn't think he'd be
able to play that they threw the ball a
little bit on Friday he played that
Saturday had to come out of the game so
you know I understand it's you know
concern I do but it's it's a game of
toughness on a game but it's never seen
the game and and Stewart stood on the
sidelines would figure out this this is
not a game that's good for your body
just so you know I guess driving a race
car is probably not or walking around on
beams when I work construction in
college you know the walking around
those beams up on you know ten floors up
that's not real smart either so you know
I just the the part I really took took
issue with those you know lumping that
in with with head trauma which i think
is a totally different topic a very
serious topic certainly and one that you
know is going to get a lot continue to
get a lot of attention deservedly so but
even on that topic you know I just go
back 15 years ago they really
to treat treat concussions
there wasn't a formal rehab program
unless a person was really you know
affected by it otherwise it was a return
to play that was really quick and you
know the world's changed so much
medically and I'll go back 30 years ago
if you got an ACL injury or repair you
may or may not be able to function
afterwards so I think we were learning a
lot more about head trauma and
everything in medicine we've got an
unbelievable medical staff here and we
have never played a player without
clearance from our medical people so
just you know that I'm not saying it was
directed at us necessarily but the
insinuation the innuendo that came out
of that article I found to be a little
bit hurtful quite frankly a couple more
minutes a couple more minutes in a few
Noman two more questions for Coach
Ference from Iowa here on the Rich Eisen
show I couldn't help but notice a very
touching moment during your game when
the fans paused game pause and everybody
stood up and waved and had an ovation in
the direction of the Children's Hospital
next to the stadium what is the genesis
of that coach you know part of it's just
good dumb luck quite frankly Richards
you know the the Children's Hospital
it's a project and my wife's been kind
of involved with that since our kids
left school she's gotten very involved
and trying to help promote awareness for
the for the stud Children's Family
Hospital and so long story short you
know we started ladies football academy
years ago I think we've raised close to
two million dollars now in the last six
years seven years and we actually have a
room that faces the stadium that's named
after the program in lady's football
academy are our players volunteer to get
involved in that but the way beyond that
are all of our programs not just
football but all of our programs have
had a real good relationship with the
Children's Hospital
you know how fortunate we've for our
players to have a chance and coaches to
go over and meet the patients their
families yeah and really what it does it
just does a great reminder for our
players that you know we're able to do
this and B we choose to do this and you
know not everybody is that lucky so it's
been great that way but yeah they just
built a brand new children's house what
just comes right up over our East East
bleachers and in our stadium so the
partnership is there
you know in in real life but it's also
there between the hospital and Stadium
I'm not sure whose idea it was but it's
a great idea and it's awesome it's just
it was fantastic it really is great and
you know and I just wanted to just give
you a you know an ovation for that and
pass that along to to the whole staff
there that to come up with that idea
it's it's just a small thing that just
goes such a long way and I I love it
last one for you to take credit for it's
one more thing I did thank okay it's all
good
yep you you represent fun to be part of
it though last one for you I couldn't
help but notice that you know in your
last season with the Baltimore Ravens
being part of the offense and obviously
offensive line being your forte
positionally the quarterback that you
were helping protect in that last season
in 1998 is you go ahead say his name go
ahead say it's very funny funny how
things go around and go ahead you could
say he's like I can give you a better
trivia my last game was Barry Sanders
last game get out of him Baltimore has
his last game in the NFL my game in the
last game in the NFL and okay he's a
heck of a lot more famous than I am for
everything I'll say the quarterbacks
named Otis Brockman he would not say the
quarterbacks name not Jim Harbaugh was
the quarterbacks name of the Baltimore
Ravens so on behalf of all Michigan
Wolverines fans thank you for protecting
him best you could that there you go
and and and man you you you ripped my
heart out and showed it to me pumpin
last year though but that's that's what
Big Ten competition is all about you
know I gotta tell you I had a daughter
that went to Michigan and Mary Sue
Coleman to Georgia I was it was the
president that hired me at Iowa and I
was told Mary Sue I said you know
telling you to fall back school she
couldn't get in and Iowa had to go to a
fallback school so she did that but
unfortunately she came back here and got
some graduate work done so we've got her
straightened out coach I really enjoyed
chat with you I'd love to do it more
more and more often this is a lot of fun
appreciate respects ray I've got it you
got it good luck against Iowa State big
game in the state of Iowa this week
versus Iowa State that's Kirk Ferentz
here on the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country
and audience if you liked that video be
sure to download our app and I'll be
sure to help the NFL figure out what it
catches